[Music]
from a director who wants to stop
obsessing over serial killers but the
voices in his head make him do it again
and again and again and coming soon
again comes a twisted tale that will
change films Forever by making them
replace title letters with numbers and
thinking that it's in any way cool it's
not
Superman
head on down to the city which one they
never say I've worked homicide five
years not here so how long have you
lived here too long I hate this city
where it's always pouring rain
thank you
the people are scum do you like what you
do for a living
no I don't and even the possessed
durables are holding housekeepers
hostage
in a hard-boiled cop film who's Bleak
tone to find the next few decades until
sometime around 2010 when homicide
detectives all turned back into sassy
Aristocrats
there are no Killers here this crime
clashed
with the presence of Benoit Blanc I say
I see uh the murderer here appears to
have fared this last creature for my
word journey to a city that needs Jesus
and or Batman but all they got is Mills
and Somerset one detective is almost out
of to give this can't be my last Duty
it's just going to go on and on and on
you're retiring the other too many [__]
to handle
um
what's in the [__] box follow along
on somerset's Journey from a sad
irritable lonely man two well still that
but he's more or less at peace with it
in one of Morgan Freeman's many roles as
black guy who is too old for your white
nonsense
he's backed up by a Powerhouse
performance from Brad Pitt playing a man
10 less dumb than he was in Burn After
Reading
array numbers and dates and numbers and
numbers and dates and numbers Marquis De
charday the Marquis whatever and joining
him is real life girlfriend at the time
Gwyneth Paltrow a pregnant woman with
the only moments of kindness in the
whole story so you just know they'll do
something like chop her head off and
mail it to her husband
this is Fincher we're talking about
Embrace The Edge return to when Kevin
Spacey had to play a role to creep you
out you're looking for me as brutal
serial killer John Doe he's taking
virtue signaling very literally in a
seven-day spree that gets lazier as it
goes along where by the weekend he's
trotting out jigsaw's B material
sleeping pills flew to one hand so if
I'm glued to the other then like a
teenager realizing his product is due
the next day goes uh I I wish I was the
cop I met two days ago that makes me
Envy right does that work oh man I can't
believe I blew the whole year on sloth I
got a hair sample I got a stool sample I
got piss I got fingernails tired of cop
movies where they try their best all the
time get ready for a more realistic look
at the profession
wake up glimmer twins
we're Somerset and Mills generally just
wait around
this is the job maybe you guys want to
cross your fingers somewhere else catch
up on their reading list
fall back on their go-to of suspending
civil rights
and how is this legal
he's the only on these terms don't apply
and utterly fail to get their man or
stop a single murder from occurring John
Doe has the upper hand yeah your partner
wears the same children's basketball tie
every day I'd say he's got the upper
hand so let the punishment fit the grime
in a film that opens with a nine inch
nail song and somehow gets more silky
from there that's sure to churn your
stomach with a real-life villainous
Mastermind if I didn't pay the price for
the things we both know I did do I'm
certainly not going to pay the price for
the things I didn't do Twisted
descriptions of torture that's even
worse than seeing it he put that thing
on me he made me do it and just a big
bucket of puke to the face for good
measure
what's in it
that's still a beautifully crafted
bummer with just the right amount of
humor to lighten the mood dead dog
I didn't do that it's funny because the
dog died of natural causes
story
Morgan Freeman Once Upon a Time in uh
Seattle pepper plops the Box Troll seven
I didn't understand that high shaft in
City Hall and all Cox rolls are
I'm alive
To Kill a Mocking nerd
it's really too bad this didn't lead to
other numerical list themed Killer
movies there are seven deadly Sans
Captain there are four basic food groups
Captain there are seven dwarves Captain
there are ten little piggies captain
what's in the box when you have nausea
heartburn indigestion upset stomach
diarrhea mommy is with the maggots now I
declare bankruptcy
follow me on Tick Tock at Epic voice guy